news this morning u.s officials say more
than 90 percent of federal workers have
received at least one coveted shot
before the president biden's deadline
which is today this of course while
covet is still raging on and unlike last
year when the world hadn't quite
reopened yet people are back and they
are mingling together and with that
comes a heightened risk of not only the
coronavirus but seasonal flu the cold
bianca holmen is live this morning with
some advice from local doctors on how we
can tell the difference bianca good
morning to you good morning cold flu
coven 19. people with severe cases can
end up in urgent care so we spoke with
local doctors to share about each one
and how you can tell the difference so
allergies if you have those seasonal
usually come with itchy nose eyes and
and watery eyes cold that can include
itchy nose eyes along with a stuffy nose
and if you have the flu
most likely you'll have a fever aches
and fatigue cover 19 all the same
signs as the flu along with loss of
taste and smell after a while we spoke
with dr john who says cold flu and covet
very contagious and can spread quickly
these are infectious diseases they
spread through the air or through
droplets or are lying on surfaces that
then we can touch and
get into our bodies
it's important to keep in mind that flu
symptoms also start suddenly but cold
and allergies those progressed slowly
cobit that takes even a little bit
longer to feel sick after you've been
exposed and so coming up in the next
half hour i'm going to share another way
you can figure out the difference and
also ways to stay healthy this season
bianca holman live local now